You know how, like,
when you're exercising, they say to take progress pictures
so that you can see where you started from.
Like, journal,
do something in some way to document what you're feeling
so that you'll know, like,
when the moment comes where you're thinking,
should I go back?
Should I just undo it all and just forget that this happened,
you can remember why you left.
And when you're having a hard moment in the future,
you can look back on other hard moments you had and be like,
well, fuck,
I made it through that, too.
You know what I mean? Like,
if she can do it, so can I.
You know, past me,
did it, currently can do more.
I can keep going, you know?
And when you can't look to that,
you can look to the other.
If she can do it, I can do it.
It's just a big Fucking Game,
Spider Man, where we fucking find our freedom and happiness.
So excited for you. Truly trust the process.
It really. Read all the comments,
follow all the people that,
you know, strike a nerve with you.
That feel like, okay,
she's kind of feeling the vibe or she gets,
you know, because you do kind of start to rebuild your whole life.
You're gonna rebuild friends. Like,
you know, shit you never thought possible will happen
in good ways and in bad ways.
You Know, people helping you that you never thought would help you,
or people turning their back on you that you never thought would.
Whatever the fuck. But I guarantee you,
life is gonna be so much better
when you actually have a say in what happens.
I'm so truly, so fucking excited for you.
And I'm sending you like, so much love and encouragement.
Cause when you know, you fucking know.